denn weder hat schnee in sich drin
löw meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer neuen folge der
minecraft kommen hier am dienstag und
zwei stelle ich euch heute wieder einen
tut mir leid das ist die ganze schweine
getötet das war irgendwie andere flecken
ich stelle euch heute wieder einen
einzelnen command vor die sonne geht
gerade wunderschön hier auf und dieser
command ist sehr sehr umfangreich ich
weiß nicht ob ich euch die letzte
funktion noch zeigen kann weil ich
gerade nicht so viel zeit habe denn es
ist schon 13 uhr 1 übrigens jahr meine
apple watchers angekommen an alle helfer
jetzt wieder hier ja dieser command
walter das sieht richtig nass aus
das einfach im berg schlucht drin
das sieht richtig hammer aus hier an
alle die den zieht haben möchten deshalb
kurz - 77 44 42 wir fangen mit dem
command würde ich sagen ich nehme mir
meinen command blog setzte ihn hier
vorne hin setzte ein hebel daneben und
fluege.de command ein indem ich einfach
den command mit strg v 1 gebe einen
hebel dort hinsetzen und ihr seht schon
das ganze ding ist relativ groß aber das
ist nicht der einzige command sondern
dieser komplette command besteht aus
drei commerce und zwar ist der von super
ten boy und heißt fries wenn etwa das
ist jetzt quasi erst mal so der erste
kommentar einfügen müssen damit das
ganze erstmal funktioniert jetzt gehen
wir nämlich erstmal wieder in den usa
neben uns hier schön obsidian und schön
ein feuerzeug machen uns hier so ein
schönes portal können damit dann
wunderbar einfach ganz schnell in den
neckar reisen und dort erwartet uns
sitzt nämlich nach uns erwartet
eigentlich nichts aber wir müssen jetzt
noch da zwei andere command blöcke
hinsetzen so jetzt sind wir im netz
angekommen durch den kula shaker sie das
alles relativ dunkel aus das heißt ich
warte mal eben kurz raus das problem ist
jetzt wir müssen nämlich irgendwo hin wo
die deckenhöhe sehr hoch ist das heißt
beispielsweise ich hier wäre es mehr
oder weniger perfekt da hierauf direkten
gast in der nähe ist und zwar gehe ich
jetzt kurz hier in meine textdatei die
ich mir hier mal anlegen wenn ich
commands vorstelle und hab mir jetzt den
zweiten ko man kopiert den ich jetzt
hier einfüge jetzt seht ihr schon jetzt
kommt hier wieder so ausgebildet wenn
das oben den red storm blog erreicht ist
das ganze hier kreiert jetzt kommt
nämlich jetzt eine kleine eismaschine
genau und jetzt hole ich mir noch eben
schnell
nächsten command weil das ganze noch aus
einem dritten command bestätige ich auch
noch dazu packen muss so den habe ich
jetzt kopiert flüge ihn hier wieder ein
und ihr seht schon jetzt generiert sich
wieder etwas und wenn da oben wieder der
red star blog erreicht wird sehen wir
auch schon wieder unten generiert sich
noch eine maschine soll jetzt haben wir
erst mal den kompletten command kreiert
und ich muss jetzt erstmal irgendwie
mein portal wieder wo genau war das
portal das ist immer das a pad portal
aber das ist immerhin das problem bei
mir wenn ich ein netter gehe nirgendwo
hin und dann weiß ich nicht mehr wo das
portal ist jetzt ist nämlich die aufgabe
dass wir hier erst mal ganz viel schnee
hin packen da können wir eigentlich so
viele packen wir wollen wir können noch
einen theoretisch einfach ganz viele
schneemänner bauen aber ich habe gerade
mehr lust daran hier irgendwie bisschen
schnee einzusetzen
jetzt geben wir den gamern 0 und nehmen
uns jetzt irgend eine x-beliebige
schaufel und graben wir jetzt ein
bisschen schnee weg bis wir eine
bestimmte sorte schnee bekommen dass sie
mein handy bimmelt die ganze zeit ich
hoffe ihr hört das nicht
ich hatte ja diese leute sich nicht in
eine nachricht fassen können sondern
alles so 1000 1000 nachrichten schreiben
und ich glaube dann richtig jetzt hier
einfach mal kurz zum schneemann und zwar
im rc den schneemann und das gute ist
dass der schneemann hier ja dauerhaft
immer schnee generiert das heißt ich
kann quasi jetzt die ganze zeit hier
draufklicken und jetzt warten wir mal
und jetzt müsste nämlich gleich jeden
moment etwas spornen wo wir uns alle
denken
damit macht der ganze command endlich
auch mal drin um mein gott frames
regatta chat seht ihr das da sind die
welle nach einer langen reise bis
endlich ja jetzt erst mal schön hier
inventar aus werne das ja auch genug
platz hat hierfür
da haben wir's ab sie bloß nobody's
novosti mode special soll das heißt okay
das ist ja schon mal schön irgendwas
besonderes macht date schmeiße ich immer
meine schneebälle weg und jetzt legen
nämlich auch schon der grund warum ich
hier eine komplette diamant rüstungen
habe und zwar begeben wir uns jetzt
wieder in den network
ok jetzt haben ein anderes problem ich
finde gar nicht mehr dem platz wo a
hier war das ganze und zwar es hier
schon perfekte haben wir nämlich auch
gerade diese beiden anderen kommt noch
mal und jetzt begebe ich mich in den
game mode 0 im netz
was er eigentlich schon phase der tod
bedeutet und dieser gas da hinten muss
mich jetzt nur möchte mich nicht
angreifen oder wie jetzt greift er mich
an und zwar wenn jetzt eine rote kugel
von dem auf mich zukommt kann ich da
einen schneeball drauf werfen und ihr
seht schon
denner hat schnee in sicht denn genau
das gleiche kann ich jetzt rein
theoretisch auch kummer dahin müssen
gast rein theoretisch wenn der gast da
hinten mich jetzt von hinten kommt auch
noch einer
also wenn der gast mich da vorne jetzt
abschließt oder kommen wir nehmen mal
den nach hinten wo ist er denn dass die
unterallgäuer dahinten der schießt
schießt der mich ab schmeiße ich hier
drauf und da sehen wir schon wird das
hier zum zum schnee und jetzt greifen
mich so die zombie pigment verwandeln
sich zu so kleinen dingen sting an hier
und warte ich wie ich jemals wieder ein
game und 1 das ganze zu erklären ganz in
ruhe also was ich gerade getan habe ist
ich habe den sub zero snowball genommen
habe ihn auf den gas geworfen bzw nicht
auf dem gas direkt sondern auf diese
rote feuerkugel die der gast auf mich
geschickt hat und dadurch ist dort wo
die beiden dinge miteinander kollidiert
sind ist diese eisfläche entstanden bzw
dahinten dieser andere als fläche und
wenn jetzt rein theoretisch ihren song
widmen da rein läuft wir sind so viele
aber keiner will der einlauf ist egal
wenn da jetzt in zombie pickt man rein
läuft wird er zum zusammen kleinen
schneemann und greift mich an und auch
wenn die da schon von anfang an drin
waren
das heißt der hier befindet sich gerade
sehr in der nähe oder möchte nicht mal
jemand von euch hier du siehst ja das
möchte man ihn gern mal rein laufen hier
dann drücken wir den zombie pigment
nehme ich jetzt mal rein und dann seht
ihr schon jeden moment
da isa und jetzt haben wir so einen
kleinen racker und der greift mich jetzt
an und wenn er mich trifft wenn ich im
game und klang samt effekt und so weiter
und so fort und jetzt schlage ich den
mal und der drop dann diese nitrogen
crystals und hier sind unter anderem
auch noch ein paar mehr von diesen sub
zero snowboards die halt auch unter
unter anderem einmal so gedruckt werden
da hinten müssten auch noch irgendwie
ein paar liegen
mal schauen ob hier noch irgendwo einer
ist genau hier fordern wir auch noch ein
und hier vorne aber noch mehr von diesen
kleinen racker nieren und wenn ich diese
sachen die diese droppen diese nitrogen
christel wenn ich dir jetzt rein
theoretisch in den rhein werfen dann
bekomme ich so eine seinen kleinen trank
der wasser erzeugt im netter was ja
eigentlich unmöglich ist das heißt ich
habe mir jetzt mal eben hier nan goldin
und ich hole mir wasser damit ihr das
mal sehen könnt wasser kam rein und wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise diese nitrogen
christa rhein wäre
so da hat man es gerade gesehen ich weiß
nicht ob es aufgenommen habe aber ich
habe diese nitrogen christ ist
eingeworfen
das wasser ist weg und ich habe mich
verarschen muss dann muss die puschen
hin muss die puschen ich kenne mich mit
brown nicht überhaupt nicht gut aus also
ich weiß die hier rein oder ich weiß
hier vier stück auf einmal rein und
nichts passiert eigentlich sollte da ist
eine passion rauskommen und wenn ich
diese passion werfe unter wasser ich
weiß nicht wieso es bei mir egal dafür
seid ihr gefragt leute und zwar in der
beschreibung findet ihr command
eingeblendet user video dazu und so
weiter und so fort er erklärt es zwar
ein bisschen kompliziert aber ich denke
das versteht man da auch ganz gut sonst
denke ich dass ich auch ganz gut erklärt
habe allerdings hat dieses ganze mit der
mit der motion hier ich weiß nicht ihr
müsst halt auf jeden fall vier von
diesen nitrogen christa reinwerfen
bekommt in einem porsche wenn er die im
nirgendwo hin wirft sonntag quasi wie
als wenn ihr den wassereimer setzt in
etwa ihr könnt das ganze einfach mal
selbst zu hause ausprobieren da könnt
ihr dann einfach den kommunen nehmen und
geben euch einfügen und so weiter und so
fort
ich beende jetzt jemand das video ich
werde schon krank weil ich so viel am
videos aufnehmen bin tag krank im kopf
weil wenn ihr das video hier seht bin
ich gerade in new york sogar schon drei
tage new york soll trotzdem gefallen hat
will ich mich über eine bewertung freuen
schreibt mir kommen und so weiter in die
kommentare wir sehen uns dann im
nächsten video wieder und zwar morgen
bei einem simulator